[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday
so much happens in the final weeks of a
presidential campaign that it's easy to
lose track of it
whatever happened to this or that
development in the news you can't
remember
a lot falls between the cracks there's
overload
politicians know this obviously and they
take advantage of it
if they can derail a story until after
election day
often that story goes away forever no
one really remembers
and that was precisely the thinking
behind the democrats response to hunter
biden's laptop
they knew from the first day that the
contents of that laptop were in fact
genuine look at what's on there it may
be theoretically possible that some
foreign intel service would photoshop a
picture of hunter biden's crotch
mostly for self-amusement but a hundred
pictures of hunter biden's crotch
adorned with m m's no no russian did
that
those pictures were real and so were the
huge numbers of emails and texts from
hunter biden
explaining how he was selling access to
his father then the vice president and
how his father was helping him do it
so in order to enrich his family joe
biden changed this country's foreign
policy
that happened and it was the real crime
that hunter biden's laptop revealed that
was the real scandal
if voters had understood that if someone
had told them it might have affected
the results of the election so they
couldn't know the program bureaucracy
hid that from the country in october a
group of corrupt intelligence officials
50 of them whose names will live forever
in
shame signed a letter blaming vladimir
putin for the laptop
hunter biden's story is russian
disinformation dozens of former intel
officials say that was the headline in
politico
that was a lie from top to bottom it was
totally unsupported by evidence or
intelligence
but it came just in time for the
presidential debate that was the point
and joe biden picked it up and wielded
it like a club
from the stage we are in a situation
where we have foreign
company countries trying to interfere in
the outcome of our election
his old own national security adviser
told him that
what is happening with his buddy well i
guess
well i will his buddy rudy giuliani
he's being used as a russian pawn he's
being fed information
that is russian that is not true
his own national security adviser that's
probably right
but it was a lie and just two months
after that debate the truth
began to leak out according once again
to politico the
intel world's favorite media tool
a person with first-hand knowledge of
the investigation conceded that
actually hunter biden's laptop was not a
russian fabrication
it was real real enough to be used as
evidence in an ongoing investigation
into quote
potential money laundering and hunter
biden's foreign ties
hunter biden we learned was facing
possible indictment for what was on the
laptop the doj was looking into the
ukrainian and chinese businessmen
who'd been paying hunter to get close to
his father and they wanted to know why
his father was apparently getting 10
of those deals that's what we learned
and that's
all we learned for six months we heard
nothing more
meanwhile hunter biden got a lot richer
he sold a book that no one read for
millions of dollars simon schuster paid
him off
he sold paintings he would never hang
anywhere for possibly even more than
that we don't know
because the identities of the people who
bought them are still secret
but what you do know for certain is that
hunter biden was never charged with
anything why is that it's kind of weird
if you think about it given that biden
himself hunter biden admitted on
television
that the laptop actually didn't come
from the kremlin
watch was that your laptop for real i
don't know
i know but you know that's this i really
don't know okay the answer is
you don't know yes or no if the laptop i
don't have the idea i've
no idea so it could have been yours of
course certainly it
there could be a laptop out there that
was stolen from me that could be that i
was hacked it could be that that was the
that it was russian intelligence it
could be that it was stolen from me
oh so you'd think a clip like that where
he admits it
the 50 intel officials were all lying
you think that clip would be a key piece
of evidence
in the probe into hunter biden's
finances where did all this money come
from why are foreign governments sending
him millions of dollars
emails on that laptop directly implicate
hunter biden
in his family's foreign influence
peddling operation joe biden his brother
son so why haven't we heard anything to
this day about any of this from the
department
of justice good question and today we
got our answer naturally it came from
politico
the magazine reported meaning it was
told likely for complex reasons we can
never really know
that the u.s attorney in the state of
delaware a man called david weiss
had in fact buried the hunter biden case
and
done so on purpose because he was asked
to do it
david weiss decided to do all of this
politico told us because he wanted quote
to avoid taking any actions that could
alert the public to the existence of the
case in the middle of a presidential
election
well they're just saying it out loud now
he didn't want to hurt joe biden in
other words
and he did this at the request of the
biden family and their lawyers we
learned that from the politico piece too
it includes this quote
to weiss's credit he listened said a
person
involved in the discussions in other
words he listened to the bidens
and their lawyers and because he did
that apparently david weiss has kept his
job as a federal prosecutor
now ben schreckinger of politico
needless to say strongly approves of
this it's not a subversion of justice
it's the right thing
quote weiss's decision to avoid
revealing the investigation a move that
might have boosted donald trump's
campaign
even at the cost of politicizing the
probe was consistent with his
sober-minded approach to the job
attaboy got that when you cover for a
democratic presidential campaign
you are according to politico and ben
schreckinger a
sober-minded prosecutor you did the
right thing good job david weiss
used our justice system to get the right
team into the white house
hope you get rewarded and in case you
have any doubt that that's exactly what
happened nothing to do with the time
frame before the election you should
know and you may already know
if the fbi had hunter biden's laptop for
an entire year
before the election we know they made a
forensic copy of the hard drive
in 2019 but they did nothing and they
still have it now they don't have time
they're too busy hunting down senior
citizens who talk about election
integrity
the fabled insurrectionists they can't
do anything about the subversion of
americans foreign policy by the bidens
because they're busy with the
insurrectionists maybe
someday when it no longer matters
politico will tell us that story
in the meantime we can look forward to
more treatment like this for dissidents
who oppose the regime in any way
as a reminder here's what happens to any
american who mocks the people in power
exclusive footage you're looking at
right now from cnn as the fbi arrives at
roger stone's residence in fort
lauderdale florida taking him into
custody
they arrived before dawn there before 6a
or just after 6 a.m a dozen officers
were told
that was roger stone of course they
rousted him and his
wife both of them senior citizens by the
way
because he made the mistake of texting
unflattering things about federal
prosecutors and the government read his
texts
but hunter biden doesn't have to worry
about any of that he doesn't have to
worry about the swat team showing up at
his house at dawn with a cnn camera crew
in tow
hunter biden can violate all the federal
gun laws he wants and he has and he
knows he'll never be charged
merrick garland works for his dad so
he's fine he can do literally whatever
he wants and as we've seen
he definitely has but there's a
different standard for you if you
step out of line you're done hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else